hi there steve kaufman here
um
pretty excited my wife and i are leaving
uh on our trip in two days
uh we're gonna go uh first to the cook
islands for three days and then we'll be
in new zealand for five or six and then
in australia for about two weeks
i'm hoping to meet up with some of you
um i will put my schedule here in the
comments it looks like uh march the
second in auckland
uh we're gonna meet up at my hotel which
is the aristotle's north shore or
something i'll put this in the comments
section
uh
march the 9th in melbourne it'll be
march the 16th in sydney i'm going to
put this in the comments section as well
brisbane march 21st
looks like we have a few people in each
location uh
uh i look forward to meeting you all
while away i have spent the last few
days cranking out a bunch of videos in
different languages to complete my
seven secrets to
successful language learning and
i finished the ones in japanese russian
french and spanish so that they're
complete and alex will gradually be
releasing them so that my channel
doesn't
lie empty while i'm away i also bought
myself
a little snowflake
you know microphone because normally i
use this blue snowball here
and if it's uh convenient i may even do
a podcast or at least a video while i'm
traveling so i look forward to meeting
you
and bye for now